if I'm really honest I'd announced Logan
was my last
and then I went to see the Deadpool
movie and I was 20 minutes in I was like
Christmas I'm like
all all I could see that whole movie was
first of all I loved the movie but all I
could see was Nick Nolte Eddie Murphy in
48 hours I was like
this is something I haven't done we
haven't done with the character that's
the kind of dynamic we haven't had
before what is going on everybody
welcome back to the cosmic wonder I'm
Warren Thompson and today we have three
really big MCU updates these are three
separate reports about three different
projects however they all tie together
of course because they have to do with
the Multiverse and some have to do
specifically with time travel and new
time travel devices that they're about
to introduce in the MCU and the other
report has to do with Spider-Man
specifically Spider-Man 4 which I know
fans are going to be super excited to
hear about but the first one that we're
going to be talking about today is
Deadpool 3 and specifically about
Wolverine and the old Logan timeline
remember Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds
said that they weren't going to touch
the old Logan timeline they're not going
to undo his death or that character Arc
that is set in stone that's not going to
be undone and yesterday Hugh Jackman
talked a little bit about that and how
that that is going to be specifically
done and it sounds like it's really
going to tie into the events of Loki and
specifically around the TVA we already
have had an announcement that Owen
Wilson's Mobius is going to play a
significant role in Deadpool 3 not just
a quick little Cameo but a significant
role and that the TVA and Miss minutes
is going to be involved as well but Hugh
Jackman actually gives us a pretty big
plot point for Deadpool 3. now since we
already know that Deadpool and Wolverine
are going to be traveling across the
Multiverse going to different universes
kind of messing things up I'm assuming a
lot of fans were wondering how exactly
are they going to do this well here is
what Hugh Jackman had to say about
Deadpool 3 the Logan timeline and a time
travel device in a recent interview all
because of this device they have in the
Marvel world of moving around timelines
now we can go back
because you know it's science and
and so I don't have to screw with the
Logan timeline which was important to me
and I think probably to the fans sir so
this was on Sirius XM in an interview
they did with Hugh Jackman as you can
see here and he says that there is a
device that they have in the Marvel
world where they can move across
timelines so they can go back and he
jokingly calls this science and this
reminds me of the quote from Thor where
he's talking to Jane and he says you
call it magic where I come from science
and Magic are one in the same but
looking at this interview clip there are
two very important things that you have
to listen for the first really important
part is that he mentions the device that
can help them move across different
timelines he is not specifically talking
about going back in time in one timeline
or the same timeline he is talking about
multiple different timelines he then
says we don't have to mess with the
Logan timeline so the Wolverine that we
are going to see in Deadpool 3 is not
going to be the Wolverine variant from
that logo in Timeline it looks like we
might get introduced to a new different
variant of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine who
will most likely be 99 the same however
it looks like Deadpool will go into a
different timeline and then go back in
time and get Wolverine this means that
they would be out of the Logan timeline
into a new one so they won't mess up the
Logan timeline this was probably one of
the stipulations that Hugh Jackman had
for returning to Deadpool 3. based off
of what Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds
have said Hugh Jackman was the one who
was really really excited to return as
Wolverine to be in Deadpool 3 however we
have heard Hugh Jackman and we have
heard Patrick Stewart talk about how
Logan really was the end for them and
they would never want to return because
they wouldn't want to undo the ending of
Loken where spoiler alert if you haven't
seen that movie both Professor Xavier
and Wolverine die and they don't want to
undo that and they didn't and both have
now returned without undoing Logan now
here is the question what exactly is
this time time travel device most people
would automatically think about Deadpool
2 the time travel device that cable had
and this is a very logical thought
however as far as we're concerned this
device can't travel between different
universes between different timelines
it's all in the same timeline this was
proven when cable decided to save
Deadpool and the bunny that he kept on
his side which was burned was no longer
burned anymore confirming that he
changed the future of that very same
timeline that he was in so as far as
we're concerned that time travel device
only allows him to travel forward and
backward in time in the same timeline
however there has recently been a report
from Insider Daniel rpk that there is
going to be a new time travel device
introduced in Loki season 2 and
considering how it does really seem like
Deadpool 3 is going to tie into the TVA
Owen Wilson's Mobius and Miss minutes
this could be the time travel device
that they use according to Daniel rpk a
new temporal concept called time Loom at
the origin of the power of the TVA is
going to be presented in Loki season 2.
and this could very well be exactly what
Deadpool and Wolverine use to travel the
Multiverse not just one timeline but the
Multiverse but what exactly could this
time Loom be we'll talk about that in
Spider-Man 4 in just a bit but first big
thank you to Ryan reynolds's company
mint mobile for sponsoring this video in
this video most people know about mint
mobile because of Ryan Reynolds but most
people don't know about mint Mobile's
amazing quality now I live in the
mountains and service isn't too good
however mint mobile sent me a free plan
and I get better service with their plan
than I do with my other provider but
what's crazy is their plan is so much
cheaper mint mobile offers Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month they give you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or a family and at mint mobile families
start at only two lines all plans come
with unlimited talk and text plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network plus mint
Mobile's modern family plan lets you mix
and match data plans so everyone gets
the amount of data that's right for them
and you can use your own phone and keep
your same number and contacts so to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month including the Modern Family Plan
go to mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
bill down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic now what is a Time
Loom well a regular loom one for weaving
is a device that helps you hold a bunch
of different threads in place so you can
weave them so you could probably see how
the TVA and Kang having a Time Loom
device make sense the time Loom would be
a device that would have multiple
different timelines or threads being
controlled by one machine now I'm
actually assuming that he who remains
had a Time Loom as well and he used the
time Loom to weave everything that he
personally wanted into one timeline that
device could be how he formed the sacred
timeline and kept all of the other
multiverses and timelines into one
weaving them in the time Loom into one
Universe now since the goal of a new
Kang the Conqueror not the goal of he
who remains who is now dead but a new
Kang is to completely conquer the entire
Multiverse I'm assuming that this time
Loom isn't being used to Simply weave
all of the universes or timelines into
one I'm expecting this device to be used
by King for time travel and Multiverse
travel this is most likely going to be
one of the ways that Kang and the TVA
can travel to several different
multiverses for the purpose of
conquering them and it's still unsure
how Deadpool and Wolverine are going to
end up being in contact with the TVA but
I wouldn't be surprised if the TVA takes
them and then they cause chaos inside of
the TVA and use this time Loom to jump
across the Multiverse that would be
funny that would be action-packed I'm
sure and it would be chaotic which I'm
sure everybody would absolutely love to
see but let me know your thoughts about
all of that in the comments down below
now to to move on to Spider-Man we have
kind of a big update depending on how
you've been viewing Spider-Man 4
recently A lot of people have stated
that Tom Holland has not signed a new
contract and yes even though Marvel and
Sony said Spider-Man 4 is coming you
still never know so there are some
people out there that doubt that we are
going to get Spider-Man 4. however we
have an update from Sony today coming
from the CEO of Sony himself when asked
about a new live-action Spider-Man movie
that isn't going to be animated hence
live action and when and if it's going
to come when asked about it in a recent
interview with The Hollywood Reporter if
we are getting Spider-Man 4 he said you
bet and when asked about when to expect
it he said when you can expect it I
don't know serve no wine before it's
time so for the doubters that Spider-Man
4 isn't going to actually happen
hopefully this puts you at ease
according to the cosmic Circus the
release date for Spider-Man 4 is set to
be July 12th of 2024 so about a year and
a half away I'm assuming once Sony gets
done with across the spider-verse stuff
and promotion we'll start to hear a lot
more about Spider-Man 4 and the MCU so a
lot of exciting things happening in the
MCU I can't wait for Deadpool 3 and of
course Spider-Man 4 and Loki season 2
but let me know how excited you are in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest news
you can always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
foreign